[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
au sommaire de ça vous regarde ce soir
où va le gouvernement le regain de
l'épidémie contraint l'exécutif à
naviguer à vue
peut-on donner deux fronts à la fois la
poursuite des réformes et la gestion du
coronavirus comment font nos voisins
européens est la présidentielle se
jouera-t-elle sur la crise sanitaire
qu'ovide le cap impossible c'est le
thème de notre grand débat ce soir nous
parlerons aussi de l'enseignement de
l'arabe à l'école c'est l'une des
mesures d' emmanuel macron pour lutter
contre la montée de l'islamisme
aujourd'hui seul un élève sur deux mille
apprend l'arabe au collège ou au lycée
faut-il renforcer cet apprentissage
réponse dans notre face à face thomas
des prêts lui reviendra dans sa
chronique sur le débat houleux sur les
mets au nicotine aux ide
le vote a eu lieu ce soir et ce
pesticides tueurs d'abeilles et bien ce
sera bien réintroduit pour sauver la
filière betterave voilà tous ces sujets
on va les aborder avec notre grand
témoin c'est un iconoclaste chez les
républicains
très à droite sur la sécurité très à
gauche sur le social il pourrait se
présenter aux régionales et pourquoi pas
en 2022
guillaume pelletier est avec nous ce
soir voilà donc pour le programme tout
de suite parce au grand débat
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
bonsoir guillaume pelletier merci d'être
avec nous c'est une première dans ça
vous regarde soyez le bienvenu vous êtes
député les républicains du loir-et-cher
numéro deux des républicains on va
passer une heure ensemble je le disais
on va parler d'apprentissage de l'arabe
à l'école mais on va parler un petit peu
de votre famille politique qui se
cherche un champion mais on va commencer
avec cette question le coc vide at-il
paralysé les réformes dans le pays
comment gouverner
quand l'incertitude est la seule
boussole bonsoir coralie dubost merci
d'être là députée la république en
marche de l'hérault j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir pascal perrineau bonsoir je
remercie d'être là politologue au
cevipof à sciences po paris
un syndicaliste va nous rejoindre dans
un instant cyril chabanier il préside la
cftc et bonsoir stéphane blakowski
bonsoir myriam et la vie de bien des
drames on porte un blouson mais mon dieu
vous faites bien nous sommes en direct
les portables sont éteints ça tombe bien
pour ouvrir le bal avec votre billet si
j'ai bien compris tout de suite si j'ai
bien compris ce soir stéphane et ben si
j'ai bien compris myriam le gouvernement
aimerait bien tourner la page du que
vides comme de tous ici mais pas pour
aller boire des coups comme vous et moi
non non le gouvernement aimerait pour
mener à bien toutes les réformes qu'il
avait promis d'engager sur le
quinquennat est alors le problème c'est
que ben le virus rôde toujours
j'ai ouvert le monde hier soir ça
m'arrive et à j'ai été surpris par une
courbe
vous allez voir assez menaçante par sa
forme c'est la courbe bleue qu'on voit
là c'est le nombre de cas de
contamination et qui grimpe sérieusement
ces derniers temps au point étudié en
droit semblait une vague une deuxième
vague du virus quoi alors est ce que
cette deuxième vague va paralyser
l'action l'action les réformes du
gouvernement
bah ce qui est sûr c'est déjà que la
présence du virus occupe à peu près tous
les esprits c'est très difficile
d'attirer l'attention sur un autre débat
empreint grant macron a fait un discours
assez remarqué quand même assez fort sur
le séparatisme islamistes habituellement
s'engage derrière ce genre de discours
une semaine de débat de polémique de
réaction là il n'y a que le virus qui
occupe les esprits dont on comprend les
journaux ce matin on prend les trois
plus gros quotidien parle du point de
vue du tirage le monde de quoi
parlent-ils est bien de recherche de
traitements la une sur le cloud vide
de son côté le parisien à la une c'est
l'effet clandestine qui attention
propage locaux vides et de son côté
figaro toujours locaux vides mais cette
fois ci qui menace les entreprises dont
il y en a que pour le coded à la une ça
veut dire que le gouvernement va devoir
attendre la fin de l'épidémie pour
poursuivre les réformes
ballard officiellement évidemment pas
question pour le gouvernement d'attendre
courage politique c'est de poursuivre
les réformes en la tempête mais en boîte
c'est déjà passé pas assez compliqué
puisque déjà sur l'assurance chômage
j'ai eu un premier recul et eu un décret
publié en juillet donc on suspend la
partie de la réforme qui a déjà été
mises en oeuvre et en plus on reporte la
deuxième partie de la réforme sur
l'assurance chômage en janvier
mais en janvier ce que vous êtes sûr que
la réforme va entrer en oeuvre en
janvier mais c'est même pas sûr quand on
en parlait la cfdt qui sont généralement
pas non plus le plus difficile à
convaincre
eh ben ils sont pas trop d'accord on
écoute laurent berger il aurait fallu
aller beaucoup plus loin parce que en
janvier on sera dans une situation où le
chômage aura encore augmenté évidemment
malheureusement je suis pas un oiseau de
mauvaise augure c'est juste une évidence
il ne se sera pas le moment de réduire
l'indemnisation des demandeurs d'emploi
donc ça c'est l'assurance chômage qu'en
est il pour les retraites c'est pareil
officiellement on affiche sa
détermination donc il ya même un
secrétaire d'état qui est chargé des
retraites alors empiétera chef qui donc
évidemment il doit dé témoigner de son
temps à justifier son emploi sinon c'est
grosse indication donc lui quand il
passe sur bfm business qu'est ce qui dit
innoncent était pas un emploi fictif
regardez l'on voit la capture d'écran on
va pas se payer 1 1 sont bfm c'est trop
cher mais la réforme des retraites aura
bien lieu
voilà il est catégorique en revanche
nous sur lcp quand on habite marc
fesneau la réforme des retraites aura
bien lieu bas quand c'est à dire l'année
prochaine en tout cas c'est pas trés
trés il est pas très catégorique semaine
sur l'année prochaine marc raynaud le
poids ministre a dit il faut regarder
les conditions qui permettront d'avoir
un débat qui permette d'avancer sur ce
sujet sans se retrouver dans une
conflictuelle 2020 et 2021
ça dépendra de la temporalité des
conditions ce n'est pas acquis de la
temporalité des conditions on a vu que
ce n'était pas acquis effectivement donc
si le gouvernement ne même pas cette
réforme en 2021 à cause du canidé ce
qu'il va l'amener en 2022
à un an des présidentielles où guillaume
pepy sera peut-être candidat c'est
délicat donc on a engendré une vraie
question est ce que le colis n'est pas
en train en fait de paralyser l'action
du gouvernement
coralie dubost ce coville au fond il
suspend tout alors les réformes
la bonne nouvelle c'est que nous avions
conduit 90% du programme d' emmanuel
macron dans les trois premières années
de mandat donc l'essentiel des
engagements de campagne du président de
la république de nos parlementaires dans
nos législatives
nous les avions tenu certaines des
réformes effectivement comme ça a été
évoqué par stéphane notamment celles de
l'assurance chômage
nous avons nous les avons suspendu parce
que le contexte des conséquences de
cette crise sanitaire et de la gestion
de crise font que nous ne nous semble
pas que ce soit le moment le plus
adéquat cela n'empêche que la première
plus grande partie du travail a été fait
et quand les conditions le permettront
elles pourront revenir ça veut dire
grave
non ça veut dire une photo toutes ses
formes et le pays elle m'a finalement on
est exactement dans la même situation
que tous les français
nous avons demandé à tous les français
d'adapter leurs activités c'est la même
chose pour nous alors nous l'adaptons
sur l'émission sur les priorités à
traiter dans le fond et nous l'adaptons
aussi dans la façon de travailler il ya
beaucoup de français en télétravail
beaucoup de français de restaurateurs
qui ont des protocoles sanitaires
particulier nous à l'assemblée c'est
pareil on va revenir là dans des temps
où nous ne sommes pas tous présents avec
des jours le jour dans l'incertitude
totale
c'est le lot de ce gouvernement et tant
pis pour les rues et de ce virus et des
français pascal perrineau gouverner
c'est prévoir quand on peut plus prévoir
est-ce qu'on peut plus gouverner on
tente de gouverner mais en effet en
ayant l'horizon bouché au fond ce qu'a
fait cette crise de lakovic 19
c'est que elle nous a privés j'espère
temporairement d'avenir il n'y a plus
d'avenir prévisible on le voit bien tout
le monde gère ses entreprises ses
organisations au jour le jour
or la réforme sa demande quoi ça ça
demande ce n'est pas toujours le cas
mais ça demande à être inscrits dans un
avenir pour lui donner du sens pour
associer si possible les citoyennes et
les citoyens à ce changement qui vient
d'en haut
et là on le voit bien le gouvernement ne
serait ce que sur la crise de lakovic 19
et le voit quand on écoute monsieur
olivier ferrand on le voit quand on
écoute le premier ministre jour après
jour on va d'inflexion en inflexion si
l'on prend un temps un peu plus long
quinze jours après on dit parfois peu le
contraire de ce qu'on a pu de 10 puis
dire qu'un jour avant non pas parce
qu'on est idiot mais parce que les
circonstances ont évolué les
circonstances ont changé on à changer
soi même sa religion vis-à-vis de la
pandémie et bien sûr la place laissée à
la réforme est ténue pourquoi parce que
les français ont complètement autre
chose en tête si vous prenez c'était
avant-hier le sondage et lab c'est tout
à fait impressionnant 73% ces trois
français sur quatre disent qu'ils sont
inquiets ou très inquiets de la crise de
lakovic 19 et donc dans ce contexte
parler d'autre chose mais c'est
complètement inaudible vous citiez à
juste titre cette affaire du séparatisme
qui va devenir d'ailleurs apparemment la
laïcité d'après ce qu'on sait ça sera
davantage compris que le séparatisme et
bien eux
on s'aperçoit qu'en effet il n'ya pas
place a été complètement écrasées et
c'est terrible pour le gouvernement mais
c'est terrible pour l'ensemble des
forces politiques
on verra tout à l'heure d'ailleurs si la
mention marei chez nos voisins européens
c'est vrai que au fond guillon pelletier
si le gouvernement est inaudible sur
tout autre sujet que la cogip 19 les
oppositions le font aussi
et voudrait aussi quelque part victime
oui vous l'avez tous dit ça s'impose à
tout le monde mais si on considère que
la politique n'est qu'une gestion au
quotidien sous la houlette des hauts
fonctionnaires eux mêmes soumis aux
expertises des experts bon pour moi
c'est pas ça la politique
là la politique c'est l'art de changer
la vie de tracer un cap de redonner du
sens moi ce que je reproche avec
beaucoup d'humilité à emmanuel macron
son intuition de 2010 cet été juste
c'était de nous dire je vais faire tout
ce que les autres n'ont pas su faire
pendant 20 30 ou 40 ans et au fond
aujourd'hui quand on écoute nos
compatriotes et
vie nous mêmes et ce qui a moins
d'insécurité est-ce que l'immigration
est maîtrisé est ce qu'il ya moins
d'impôts et de taxes
est-ce que la patrie c'est à dire la
communauté nationale va mieux et soudée
tracée vers une la lie à un débat
présidentiel qui arrivent pour se poser
ces questions mais ma question c'était
au fond cette pause inévitable en
quelque sorte dans les réformes
peut-on faire autrement c'est à dire les
français et on l'entend les biens à la
clé sondage pascal perrineau sont
inquiets et veulent savoir ce qui peut
se passer demain donc l'incertitude nous
amène à une forme de blocage le rôle du
politique ces deux ratios j'ai donné un
exemple on nous a dit tout et n'importe
quoi sur le masque tout et n'importe
quoi sur les tests on nous dit tout et
n'importe quoi sur les lits de
réanimation écouter philippe juvin et
tant d'autres médecins en france on a
cinq mille lits de réanimation le même
chiffre
le printemps dernier mais qui est aussi
à des fins qui reconnu comme bon tout à
fait vingt-cinq mille lits en allemagne
mais qu'est ce qu'on a fait pendant six
mois les français aimeraient pour vous
bien sûr qu'on est tous prêts à
respecter un certain nombre de gestes et
de critères très bien mais le rôle du
politique
en six mois c'est de dire on va doubler
le nombre de lits de réanimation pour
apporter une solution concrète à nos
compatriotes
c'est ça la politique de changes et de
l'opposition c'est que certes vous
pouvez faire autrement que de gérer
cette crise mais vous la gérez malcorra
l'est du bastion des 25 min la
comparaison avec l'allemagne vous savez
très bien je pense si vous êtes
renseigné par les médecins ne sont pas
le même type de réanimation en réalité
qui sont entendus et pas le même à marc
parent ya la réanimation s'est pas
seulement unis s'est pas seulement une
pièce sont des appareils c'est du
personnel etc
en france on est passé de 5000 à 15 ml
donc je crois déjà que c'est pas mal
les cinq milices et l héritage
effectivement des gouvernements
précédents donc on passant à 15000 je
crois qu'on a déjà démontré d'une
capacité à augmenter
vous lisez sur les impôts mais sur les
impôts on a déjà restitué des milliards
d'euros aux français depuis le début du
quinquennat avant la crise de coliques
19 et pendant cette crise de coliques 19
pendant cette gestion crise dans le
prochain budget qui est en train d'être
voté par la commission des finances et
qui arrivera bientôt devant l'hémicycle
on va encore rendre aux français et aux
entreprises
20 milliards d'impôts de production
qu'il ceux qui seront allégées pour les
entreprises alors donc on continue on a
30 milliards du budget qui partent sur
l'engagement en mettant vos comptes
réformer continuer à réformer tout en
gérant la personne n'a dit justement
ensemble de s'en tenir aux thèmes de
notre débat nous avons la présence de
monsieur chabalier syrie chabanais
bienvenue à vous d'abord et bonsoir vous
êtes président et la cftc
ces réformes ces négociations sociales
au ministère du travail où est-ce
qu'elles en sont si on prend par exemple
assurance chômage et retraite vous vous
les voyez les ministres et les
conseillers vous discuté non c'est des
sujets qu'on a demandé à être quéven
qu'il soit mis de côté ils ont été mis
de côté
donc on travaille aujourd'hui sur la
priorité et les négociations la priorité
c'est sauvegarder l'emploi et donc nous
avons évidemment travailler sur le plan
de relance on travaille aujourd'hui sur
le suivi du plan de relance parce que la
chose principale c'est que ce plan de
relance soit efficace je rappelle quand
même que c'est l'argent de tous les
concitoyens donc en tant que syndicat on
veille
parce que la cftc on veut que la dépense
publique soit efficace donc on vs que ce
plan de relance le soir on a des tas de
sujets qui ont été mis sur la table dans
un agenda social qui est extrêmement
chargé des sujets qu'on n'avait pas
forcément prévu les sujets parce qu'on
vient essentiellement des sujets posco
vide avec le télétravail avec le partage
de la valeur avec le suivi de la pld sur
le chômage longue durée donc d'état
d'elle dès le show de l'activité
partielle de longue durée l'accord qui a
été mis en place dans tous ces sujets là
qui sont des sujets forcément liés aux
qu'ovide qui sont venus intégrer la
jeune d'à sociale on prie l'essentiel de
notre temps sur la réforme des retraites
parce que ça ça pourrait demander des
efforts supplémentaires aux français
dans un temps où ils se sentent
peut-être victime d'une forme
d'injustice virus qui leur tombe sur la
tête
qu'est ce qu'on vous dit on fait une
partie la partie universel par points
mais pas l'aller prise parce qu'on nous
dit c'est plutôt ce qu'on a demandé
c'est à dire que quand j'ai eu la crise
due qu'au guide on a demandé à ce que à
la fois la réforme des retraites soient
mises de côté et que la réforme aussi de
l'assurance chômage parce que vous en
parliez soit mis de côté j'y reviendrai
dans quelques secondes
parce qu'il y avait une priorité à gérer
la priorité c'était l'emploi et que ce
sont des réformes dont on sait qu'elles
sont compliquées et que c'était pas du
tout le moment de remettre une réforme
qui va peut-être mettre des gens dans la
rue qui va créer des tensions
on a besoin d'attendre ma nourrice de
sacrifices aux français avec cette crise
mais vous savez il a raison sur l'emploi
c'est 20 par de nouveaux imprimés
simplement je vais en soutien je pense
qu'il a parfaitement raison et que
préserver les ans
- est vraiment une urgence qu'il va
falloir garder en ligne de mire pour les
mois à venir voir l'année nous verrons
combien de temps dure cette gestion de
crise et je regardais un chiffre
intéressant dans ma circonscription la
semaine dernière les mécanismes qui ont
été mis en place de soutien par le
chômage partiel par les aides aux
entreprises les fonds de solidarité etc
enfin que finalement là où on pouvait
s'attendre à beaucoup de classe pour le
mois de septembre dans l'hérault on à
38% de faillite en moins que l'année
précédente donc l'emploi préserver la
trésorerie des entreprises est préservé
et devrait si nous continuons dans la
bonne direction
ce que nous souhaitons avec ce plan de
relance où il ya énormément injecté et
là aussi la transformation les
indicateurs sont mauvais c'est quand
même le pendre le longe la macroéconomie
milliards taux de chômage qui devrait
grimper à 9 7% fin mai ag shame
machination qui restent basses les dents
voilà il faut regarder en avant
d'embaucher
je voulais terminer sur alès dernier
point dans le plan de relance il ya 40
mineurs qui viennent de l'europe ce qui
s'est passé au niveau de la solidarité
européenne ça n'était jamais arrivé au
niveau de cette dette souveraine commune
c'était quand même extrêmement important
et c'est vraiment un tour de force du
président de la république emmanuel
macron avec angela merkel face au frigo
ça a été une grande avancée tout en
étant dans la gestion crise il ya eu une
avancée politique est saluée d'ailleurs
quasiment eu neuf ans par la presse
européenne parfois même par l'opposition
guillaume pelletier sur ce point
européen
ces 40 milliards c'est l'argent des
français et des européens là encore j'ai
connu quelques bons chacallis et des
milliards d'euros que les français verse
au budget européen bref moi est quelque
chose qui m'a marqué par rapport à tout
ce qu'on dit le thème que vous avez
choisi entre le rapport gouverner la
crise on sait que la puissance publique
c'est ça le rôle des politiques est
devenue un puissance publique de prendre
un air alors c'est surprenant parce que
bridge coup la puissance publique
elle met des milliards là je vais vous
donner un exemple très concret qui a
marqué les esprits et c'était déjà le
cas plus mineures dans ma
circonscription du loir-et-cher en
sologne avec le groupe carrier une
multinationale qui faisait des milliards
d'euros de bénéfices et qui a organisé
une délocalisation de complaisance en
tchéquie laissant sur le carreau 80
familles on s'est battu comme des
dingues avec des élus locaux de toute
tendance pour obtenir des compensations
mais sans obtenir j'avais alerté bruno
le maire en 2017 2018
la compensation centrale c'est que sept
entreprises remboursent toutes les aides
publiques qu'elle avait touché de la
part des français
on nous a dit oui ça viendra on vient de
vivre bridgestone chez xavier bertrand
dans les eaux très belle 800 familles
abandonner alors l'état dit on va s'en
occuper on va recevoir on va réfléchir
on va on va reclasser mais le pouvoir
central l'état
les politiques n'ont pas le courage et
la force de dire chaque centime d'euro
que cette multinationale a touché vous
allait les rembourser 2 millions d'euros
rien que l'année dernière touchée par
cette entreprise pour qu'aujourd'hui
elle délocalise pour augmenter ses
profits
et bien cette puissance publique est
redevenu hélas une impuissance public
c'est le rôle de la nouvelle génération
de dire ça suffit
la politique c'est l'art de rendre
possible ce qui est nécessaire c'est ça
qu'il faut retrouver ensemble sur ce
point là puisqu'en fait vous arrivez
tout de suite sur les questions de
réponse politique à cette crise
c'est vrai que ce gouvernement choisit
une relance par l'offre en baissant au
fond des impôts de production ça rejoint
ce que faisait françois hollande avec
avec le cic eux et ce débat sur les
contreparties sur au fonds cible est
passible et l entreprise rejaillit et
bridgestone a touché pour reprendre
l'exemple de l'argent public du cic au
fond le gouvernement il va être jugé
aussi sur sa gestion de la crise par
rapport à une tempe de justice sociale
c'est ça qui se joue bien sûr parce que
bien au delà si vous voulez de l'enjeu
santé on voit tout de suite les enjeux
qui arrive après c'est pouvoir d'achat
justice sociale on est en france la
justice sociale une certaine conception
de l'égalité qui n'existe pas dans
d'autres pays européens
une conception assez strictes de
l'égalité fait qu en effet cet enjeu de
justice sociale qu'on soit de droite de
gauche ou d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs et est extrêmement important
aux yeux des français donc dans les
réformes
il faut je crois que c'est urgent il
faut que cet enjeu justice sociale
si la relance des réformes soit au
premier plan des préoccupations
il faut aussi moi je suis frappé on
parle chômage
on parle à juste titre on parle
également bien sûr d'autres types de
réformes comme les retraites mais il n'y
avait il pas moyen d'accrocher à la
préoccupation centrale des français sur
cette affaire du coït 19 une audacieuse
réforme en particulier sur le système de
santé
il ya eu comme ça du voilà il ya eu des
montées milliards d'euros mais mes 8 mai
c'était local oui mais l'occasion de
réformer le système de santé de manière
extrêmement profonde un même chose chez
nous de général il n'y a pas de médecins
généralistes dans nos provinces et nos
campagnes sur une décentralisation
audacieuse on l'a bien vu dans l'échec
c'est vrai que parfois la puissance
publique peut paraître un peu désarçonné
dans l'échec dans un premier temps au
mois de mars avril du pouvoir central
au début ces hésitations etc on se dit
parfois surtout quand on voyait ça pas
paris mais deux régions oseo
heureusement qu'ils avaient les
départements et les régions
1 donc ce moment est venu là je sais pas
dû alors qu avec vous il faut que vous
priant l'hôpital et l'échec des cendres
il parce que ni le département ni la
région d'un fournit des masques des
produits pour la réanimer en vain cette
parade en masse et reprenez le grand
test non moi je vous racontais de rona
les autres ambassades et tous
prenez deux départements des charentes
non non non non ça je vous assure bah
écoute j'ai enseigné vous est peut-être
dans votre région que dans ma région ça
a été l'état qui a fourni à la fois les
hôpitaux les structures les médecins
libéraux etc
je pense pas qu'on puisse être unanime
20 ans dans la description que vous
faites ce rsa par ailleurs ce qu'il
disait qui me semble juste sur la
justice sociale le partage de la valeur
c'est un travail qu'on a entamée dans la
loi pacte sur locale j'aimerais qu'on
aille toujours plus loin sur ces sujets
parce qu'il est le partage de la valeur
c'est quoi la participation
l'intéressement -notamment pas seulement
il ya on a parlé de se servir de nos
solutions
oui voilà il n'y a pas que cela mais
cela on fait partie dans la loi pacte on
l'avait d'abord travaillé sous l'angle
de la participation d'intéressement et
des plans d'épargné retraite aussi en
entreprise
on avait travaillé sur ses modalités la
l on avance et on voit que même en
simplifiant même en défiscalisant ça n'a
pas été suffisant à sensibiliser
entreprise territoire par territoire et
c'est encore difficile pour elle d'avoir
recourt systématiquement aux accords
d'intéressement et de participation de
qu'on essaie d'aller encore plus loin et
dans le cadre de ce plan de relance
on y prête aussi une attention alors là
je parle pour la majorité très
particulière il ya un groupe de travail
france relance en interne qui est sur ce
sujet qui oeuvrent pour avoir des
mesures qui accroche au dialogue social
et qui permettent aux partenaires
sociaux d'être informé de ce que
touchera aussi l'entreprise et qui a un
rapport de transparence bon qu'il puisse
y avoir un suivi aussi et qu'on ne se
retrouve pas dans les situations de
bridgestone comme ça avait été fait par
les républicains en 2008 s'est révélé
quel est votre regard de syndicalistes
sur au fond les interlocuteurs que vous
avez au sein des ministères
on a l'impression qu'il ya deux
temporalités il ya les urgences la
gestion immédiate et puis on nous a
parlé du monde d'après peut-être un peu
trop tôt avec le souci d'indépendance
vis-à-vis de la chine les
relocalisations est-ce que ce discours
là il est décalé aujourd'hui non il est
pas décaler les deux discours vont
revendre vont forcément de pair il ya
évidemment le discours d'urgence qu'on
fait aujourd'hui avec des mesures qui
sont prises des mesures d'urgence pour
éviter que encore une fois qui est un
maximum de deux personnes qui se
trouvent au chômage et donc ce sont des
mesures forcément d'urgence alors permis
juste de reprendre en disant que les
mesures d'emploi qui réussissent et des
mesures qui seront forte aujourd'hui de
l'argent qui sont mis sur la table
on va laisser un petit peu de temps
avant de savoir si ça réussit ou pas et
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on a toute
une série de réunions sur le suivi de
plans de relance et pour justement
regarder si chaque mesure et une
certaine efficacité ou pas donc restons
prudents sur l'efficacité mais des
moyens sont mis en jeu
voilà des moyens sont mis ce jusque là
on peut on peut le dire mais mais en
même temps on peut pas faire que du
court terme et il faut forcément avoir
une vision d'avenir
est ce que cette relance elle vous
vous paraît bien calibrée c'est à dire
qu'il ya des économistes qui vous disent
il ya des mesures qui sont pas
actionnable immédiatement justement il
faudrait pouvoir les utiliser tout de
suite alors que ce sont des par exemple
la baisse d'impôts ce sont des mesures
qui auront un effet mais beaucoup plus
tard
oui mais la temporalité n'est pas n'est
pas le sujet parce qu'on va avoir on a
des failles à des mesures en tout cas
qui ont qui ont une efficacité qui
devrait être d'au court terme et est
relativement efficace on l'espère et
puis il ya toute une série de mesures
qui auront une efficacité évidemment sur
du plus long terme et il faut pas
opposer les deux il faut faire les deux
alors je reviens aussi ce que vous avez
dit mais sur le remboursement des aides
publiques par exemple peut être que
d'accord enfin moi évidemment loin souci
avec ça mais je préférerais qu'on
comprenne le sujet un petit peu à
l'envers c'est à dire que on devrait
plutôt mieux conditionner les aides que
l'on donne ça éviterait d'ailleurs après
d'aller devoir faire une loi pour les
récupérer quand elles sont mal utilisés
on pourrait quand même gagné un peu de
temps là encore il sait que c'est
impossible sur le plan de relance on
peut on d'ailleurs nous on a dit que le
plan de relance était pâle et plutôt sur
la bonne voie ce qui répondait à votre
question mais on pensait qu'il pouvait
être mieux ciblés mieux conditionner
mieux équilibrée voilà il susurre ça
qu'on pourrait faire des efforts et
honnêtement on pourrait on pourrait
conditionner alors j'aimerais qu'on
aille faire un tour du côté de nos
voisins repères je voudrais prennent la
parole juste après parce qu'au fond la
question même si voilà vous nous emmener
directement sur le plan de relance l
urgence c est ce que nos voisins eux
parviennent à poursuivre les réformes
où sont ils comme nous complètement
monopolisé par la réponse à la copie de
risser wehrli est avec nous il a potassé
le sujet rires c'est à vous rappelle que
vous êtes le correspondant parisien du
quotidien le temps et chroniqueur dans
cette émission alors comment ça se passe
ailleurs
alors eh bien myriam je me demande si
tout ça n'est pas une question de
focales
ce qui est certain c'est qu'en termes de
priorité partout en europe la cobi 19 à
tout écraser la sécurité sanitaire est
devenu le sujet majeur pour tous les
gouvernements des pays de l'union
européenne
sans exception alors sur ce point à
berlin londres rome ou varsovie c'est à
peu près la même chose on ne pense
aujourd'hui qui a dompté la seconde
vague mais regardons plus précisément
est-ce que ce qui n'est pas intéressant
du point de vue des réformes c'est
l'impact du coronavirus ce qu'il a déjà
initié comme changement voire comme
transformation vous parliez tout à
l'heure on entendait parler du plan de
relance européen
est ce qu'il aurait vu le jour est-ce
que cet emprunt communautaire inédit
aurait été acceptée par les vingt-sept
s'il n'y avait pas eu justement le
risque et le danger du coronavirus
regarder en allemagne l'aco vide a
entraîné une révolution politique
puisqu'elle a littéralement ressuscité
angela merkel cette chancelière qu'on
disait fatigué prête à transmettre le
relais l'année prochaine à la fin de son
quatrième mandat
croyez vous qu'en italie le président du
conseil qu'ont été aurait réussi à
résister aux populistes comme il le fait
maintenant s'ils n'avaient pas endiguer
la pandémie et regarder aussi ce que le
coronavirus fait partout il teste
l'efficacité des administrations il agit
comme un révélateur des failles de ce
qui ne marche pas à commencer par le
système de santé partout il renforce le
rôle des états ils ravivent la politique
industrielle
on vient d'en parler mais il remet aussi
en cause le jeunisme de nos sociétés
parce qu'on doit prendre en compte les
personnes âgées donc au fond à force de
poser des questions qui fâchent à une
société européenne
la copie 19 est peut-être en train de
transformer nos pays bien plus vite que
ceux qui prétendaient les réformer merci
beaucoup merci pour cet éclairage
reisser pascal perrineau le virus au
fond ne réforme pas il nous transforme
tout à fait et nous transforme et la
lecture de richard wehrli et
passionnante parce que comme on dit dans
le discours de la grande distribution il
positive cette affaire qu'on a tous
tendance à percevoir comme étant
extrêmement négatif et c'est pour ça que
toutes ces questions sur le monde
d'après sont bienvenus parce que ce que
nous vivons c'est une grande
transformation économique social et
culturel comme l'europe on avait connu
dans les années 20 au moment de la
grande crise de 29 c de même en plateau
de parler au fond n'est même pas sorti
du jour d'après l'épidémie on parle d'un
monde qui pourrait vous
politique jusqu'à une date récente
mourey de manque d'imagination au fond
il ya eu trois périodes
il ya eu d'abord les grandes utopies
voilà qui ont fonctionné à droite à
gauche surtout à gauche où il y avait
énormément d'utopie qui sont fracassés
sur la réalité
en effet la chute du mur de berlin la
découverte de ce qui était objectivement
le communisme etc
et puis après on est rentré dans une
phase où les politiques avaient le nez
complètement collés sur le guidon et je
crois que la crise de lakovic 19 va
contraindre va contraindre au meilleur
sens du terme on a besoin de contraintes
de temps en temps va contrainte au
retour de l'imagination politique mais
une image réussi en politique
raisonnable
c'est contradictoire dans les termes et
une utopie à dimension humaine
le retour de l'imagination je vous donne
la parole mais je voudrais vous
soumettre les mots de rachida dati
s'était dans le parisien elle est un peu
plus sévère qu pascal perrineau a dit
même avant la crise ces réformes était
vouée à l'échec on parlait du 49 3 pour
passer en force sur les retraites le coc
vinolas qu'ovide est devenu le prétexte
pour ne plus rien faire et masquer
l'absence de cap du gouvernement c'est
au contraire en période de crise qu'il
faut avoir un cap
quel est votre cap corey dubost alors je
voulais revenir simplement sur la
transformation de nommer racheter des
titres vu quelques fois des propos
pourraient semer sur l'imagination la
vision mais je suis tout le retour de
l'aversion de moi je tiens vivent
aujourd'hui les 20
on le sait on a déjà discuté toutes les
deux mais j'ai suivi emmanuel macron
pour son audace et son imagination et
l'optimisme de sa volonté
mais le mythique idéal incidemment pour
cela que j'avais rejoint en marche et
que les autres appareils politiques ne
me plaisait plus ne me plaisait pas il
ne faisait pas rêver effectivement il ne
m'en porte est pas donc je pense que
cette énergie qu'il y avait en 2016 nous
sommes tout à fait capables de la faire
ressurgir en 2006 alors que le pays
s'enfonce juste sur le plan de l'analyse
de la transformation de la société
autour de la crise du coc vide
je suis d'accord et en même temps je ne
peux m'empêcher de penser si je fais un
parallélisme avec eux le siècle dernier
quand ils ont eu la grippe espagnole
il n'y avait pas eu l'élan de solidarité
non plus comme ça on n'y avait pas eu un
grand confinement pour tout le monde
c'est à dire que les transformations qui
se son gendre et autour de cette crise
sanitaire
elles sont aussi arrivés parce que nous
étions prêts je pense que nous étions en
train d'entrer dans cette société du
care etc mais de façon plus ou moins
consciente quand on dit quand plusieurs
groupes politiques veulent travailler
sur la situation des aidants et que
finalement nous légiférons dessus c'est
parce que précisément nous sommes entrés
dans une société du care et ça c'était
une société de le mot anglais pour
désigner le lien le souci de l'eau
naître la conciliatrice s'ils voulaient
d'une forme de solidarité de capitaux
vénérable exactement cette aide aux
vulnérables qui a été le souci de tous
les français qui ont joué le jeu dessus
du confinement et qui ont aussi était le
souci du gouvernement de l'état du
président de la république quand ils ont
mis à disposition tout le soutien voilà
un cap loyers aux entreprises le caire
qui avait été utilisé par martine aubry
je le rappelle en son temps pour
justement rester sur le cap les
présidentielles écouter ce que disait
jean pierre raffarin pour terminer ce
débat pour lui c'est clair la
présidentielle va se jouer à nouveau sur
le virus
ce quinquennat sera hélas celui de l'aco
vide
c'est pour ça que je crois que sur le
plan politique je vois beaucoup de gens
qui s'agitent sur la présidentielle mais
la présidentielle elle se joint sur un
dossier
la gestion de la coved vous êtes
d'accord avec ça non c'est un sujet
essentiel mais si rachida dati a raison
et pour et beaucoup aimé la l'analyse de
pascal perrineau
une phrase qui m'avait marqué ans
j'étais adolescent ou post adolescents
ont peut-être françois mitterrand avait
eu cette phrase terrible après moi il
n'y aura plus que des comptables et des
financiers et c'est vrai nous sommes
dirigés par des hauts fonctionnaires
très expert très diplômés sans doute
très intelligent mais qui ont oublié le
rapport au bon sens moi j'appelle à la
révolution du bon sens bien sûr qu'il
nous faut parler de la question
sanitaire qui est centrale mais sans
rien oublier de tout le reste
les français souffrent d'insécurité des
violences les français s'inquiètent pour
leur pouvoir d'achat et leur salaire que
fait-on réellement pour l'écologie au
fond et c'est tout le contraire de ce
que vous l'avez d emmanuel macron dans
nos territoires
il est considéré comme le grand
président des injustices des fractures
sociales économiques territoriales
il a divisé ce que la france gardait
d'unités et donc c'est un hymne
ces chèques et probablement que 2022
devra porter cette révolution du bon
sens repartir du terrain et au plus
alors je débats s'achèvent à faire un
dernier tour de table et puis vous aurez
le mot de la fin pascal perrineau je
donnerais à l'observateur que vous êtes
2022 sur la crise sanitaire mais on sent
déjà un tollé lyon pelletier est encore
à la parade je l'avais 30,50 pas liens
vers nos mêlées normal maintenant
parlement avec les français ils semblent
immenses et je vous ai pas coupé même si
j'étais pas d'accord je vous ai pas
couper sans entrer sur le fond il ya un
point quand même où je pense que il est
irresponsable de la part des politiques
aujourd'hui quel que soit son bord
partisans de s'en prendre aux
fonctionnaires et aux hauts
fonctionnaires hauts fonctionnaires en
fonction que j'admirais fonctionner mais
pas les vuvuzelas coupez je n'ai pas
d'accord avec vous ça fait 2 120 débat
c'est un débat
j'avais la politique alors la sape
opérationnel et vous écoute là dessus
donc vous ne voulez pas qu'on s'attaque
aux hauts fonctionnaires g distincts
juste parce que dans cette période de
gestion crise qui dure depuis quasiment
un an pas encore mais on y est depuis
plusieurs mois vous savez que qui a géré
justement la logistique les prises de
décision le fait que tout le monde
puisse être fournis alimenter et ses
territoires les hauts fonctionnaires
je suis désolé vous d'intercontrats
j'éternue les procès liés ce que je
termine mon propos et il faut que vous
l'acceptez alliés c'est ça la politique
analysait pas couper ma part que vous
n'êtes pas par exemple aller aux jeux
sur les hauts fonctionnaires jean
première c'est scandaleux pour un
politique de se cacher de cacher son
défaut d'idées en s'en prenant
l'administration comme ça vous créez de
la défiance vis-à-vis de la fonction
publique et c'est une mauvaise chose
allez vis-à-vis de la monsieur samba
général de écouter les salariés remarque
très importante la première sur la
question vous avez posé ce que c'est
trop tôt pas trop tôt pour parler du
monde d'après sait jamais trop tôt il
faut en parler dès maintenant parce
qu'on a le souvenir de 2008 avec la
crise financière où ça serait plus
jamais pareil et on a recommencé
exactement de la même manière donc ça il
faut l'arrêter et aujourd'hui il faut
faire le monde après je me permets une
dernier sur
le sujet central que vous aviez posé sur
les réformes s'arrête elle s'arrête pas
il ya deux réformes qui sont
complètement différentes
il ya l'assurance chômage qui est une
réforme qui est profondément injuste qui
a été fait à un moment donné où la
situation économique allait plutôt bien
qui aujourd'hui ce n'est plus du tout le
cas et cette réforme s'attaque au delà
elle est quasiment enterré elle est
reportée au mois de janvier elle n'est
pas enterré le gouvernement nous dit
encore qu'elle sera qu elle sera
prolongée en tout cas qu'ils veulent
garder la philosophie c'est une grave
erreur
on peut pas d'un côté mettre beaucoup de
moyens sur l'appel des le chômage
partiel et en même temps aller sur une
réforme de l'assurance chômage est bien
sûr le contraire et je termine de
quelques mots sur la réforme des
retraites c'est autre chose c'est pas le
bon moment parce que c'est un sujet qui
crée des tensions
il faut régler d'autres problématiques
sur une réforme des retraites pour un
régime universel par points
on continue la cftc de penser que c'est
une bonne idée mais c'est pas le bon
moment dit c'est dit et vous avez une
élue de la majorité qui manifestement
vous a bien entendu le mot de la fin
pascal perrineau sur la présidentielle
au fond c'est intéressant parce que on
entend gimp et essaie de faire le bilan
va presque d'avant le qu'ovide
d'emmanuel macro est ce que ce sera
audible
est ce que cette présidentielle va se
jouer sur cette crise sanitaire ce jour
off beaucoup sur la crise sanitaire mais
pas uniquement
1 ça sera l'occasion pour les français
de père et un retour sur un quinquennat
ça s'est passé comme ça avec françois
hollande ça s'est passé comme ça avec
nicolas sarkozy
ça se passera aussi comme ça avec
emmanuel macron même si il a connu mais
nicolas sarkozy avait connu le
tremblement de la crise financière et
voilà les français ont porté un jugement
sur le quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy
mais je crois pour terminer si vous
voulez que puisqu'on parle de réformes
ce qui est important c'est l'esprit de
la réforme et c'est peut-être l'occasion
cette crise de lakovic 19 de changer un
peu l'esprit de la réforme en france la
réforme vient tout le temps d'en haut en
france les français n'en peuvent plus
ils n'en peuvent plus sous la droite
c'est venu d'en haut
sous la gauche c'est venu d'en haut sous
mac ronces est venu d'en haut et je
crois que l'heure est venue de la co
construction
chaque texte merci beaucoup d'avoir
participé à ce débat je vous garde avec
moi guillaume pelletier parce qu'on va
parler un petit peu de vous m'a parlé
aussi tout de suite de votre famille
politique qui se cherche difficilement
il faut le dire un champion comment va
la droite
comment franchement va la droite
guillaume pelletier et les républicains
en particulier
on sort de vous savez ça fait pendant
dix ans on a perdu les présidentielles
et législatives et européennes donc on
pourrait dire que tout va bien et se
raconter des histoires c'est pas vrai on
est convalescent
je pense même un peu mieux avec
christian jacob depuis un an on a fait
un énorme travail
on a remporté les élections municipales
56% des villes sont dirigé aujourd'hui
par les républicains on a remporté les
sénatoriales ont remporté les élections
législatives partielles les mêmes
problèmes de ligne politique de leader
chez viens j'y viens la première étape
vous avez faut toujours être très
modeste et tirer des leçons
j'écoutais pascal perrineau il a raison
la droite aussi ces quarante dernières
années
c'est mon âge a failli et donc si on
veut vraiment réenchanter le rêve
français est parlé à nouveau à nos
compatriotes et avoir de l'imagination
parce que moi ça fait très longtemps que
la politique ne me fait plus rêver mais
c'est pour ça que j'ai envie d'en faire
c'est pour redonner envie aux français
de s'y intéresser
il faut poser un bon diagnostic 1 il
fallait remettre tout le monde autour de
la table c'était tout le travail
remarquable de christian jacob
avec damien abad avec bruno retailleau
et tous les talents de la famille
politique xavier bertrand valérie
pécresse françois baroin devant la
deuxième étape
elle vous semble peut-être secondaire
pour moi les centrales et projet
qu'avons nous à proposer et à dire aux
français le projet ce sont les idées qui
mène le monde
pour l'instant on voit différentes
lignes encore et ses bateaux mais je
vais revendre mais je voudrais et la
troisième chose avait raison viendra le
temps les hameaux l'été prochain
l'incarnation parce que la politique
heureusement ça reste aussi une
incarnation serait quand même qu'on
regarde un petit peu qui prétend à
l'élection suprême parce qu'ils sont
nombreux dans votre famille politique on
en parle tout de suite
après tour d'horizon pour 2022 côté
républicain c'est signé nathalie guy
loire qui pour porter les couleurs des
républicains à la présidentielle
celui qui semblait pouvoir mettre tout
le monde d'accord c'est françois baroin
le maire de troyes entretient cependant
le doute
même quand ce sont les militants les
républicains qu'il interroge alors
candidat ou pas c'est pas trop parce que
si nous sommes entre nous dans cette
salle à partager nos valeurs se passe
dans ma famille nous adressons aux
républicains en plus personne ou presque
n'y croit alors les regards se tournent
vers xavier bertrand le président des
hôtes france est déjà en campagne
vous savez ma détermination à être
candidat donc je vais pas me cacher
derrière mon petit doigt
sauf que xavier bertrand n'est plus
membre des républicains depuis 2010 est
pourtant le rapprochement est en marche
la semaine dernière il a déjeuné avec le
président du parti
c'est le signal d'abord que les portes
et les fenêtres de nos partis politiques
sont ouverts c'est signale que nous
sommes tous sauf sectaire et c'est
signale aussi de la volonté de xavier
bertrand de s'ancrer à droite elle non
plus n'a plus sa carte aux républicains
elle aussi est présidente de région
valérie pécresse pourrait se lancer dans
la course à 2022 le sénateur vendéen
bruno retailleau lui est très claire ce
serait candidat et puis il y un rachida
dati qui a semé le trouble avec une
interview à un quotidien britannique
pas encore partante mais elle n'exclut
rien et surtout veut montrer que la
droite ne manque pas de présidentiable
faute de candidat naturel comment
choisir 2017 a laissé des traces l'idée
d'une primaire donne des sueurs froides
aux ténors du parti
la primaire est devenu un gros mot chez
les républicains ont dit désormais mode
de départage il sera fixé au printemps
et avant ou après avoir trouvé leur
candidat les républicains devront aussi
cherché et trouvé une ligne politique
claire
voilà ça fait quand même pas mal de
chantiers encore sur la table vous êtes
plutôt retailleau non non non moins vous
êtes plutôt stimulant pécresse
- vous serez petit qui m'intéresse c'est
d'offrir aux français une alternative au
duel mortifère macron le pen dont plus
personne ne veut et qui sont complices
de manière organisée cynique d'un
effondrement de notre part qui a le plus
envie quand on va dans des je veux bien
panel seule loin la ligne que nous
portons et christian jacob et tant
d'autres c'est la ligne d'une droite
sociale et populaire parmi ceux xavier
bertrand l'incarnent assez parfaitement
il vient des territoires il est très
ancrée il défend les intérêts des
français
mais la question d'incarnation deviendra
après ce qui compte pour nous
fondamentalement nous la nouvelle
génération ce sont des idées et je vois
quatre urgent si vous me permettez ce
que ces salles qui est intéressant dans
la vie politique il débat public
la première urgence dont on me parle
tous les jours c'est la question des
salaires en france et salaires sont trop
bas
inique et tous les salaires il n'ya plus
d'écart entre les revenus du travail et
les revenus de l'assistance entre
quelqu'un qui fait l'effort d'aller
travailler et celui qui ne travaille pas
il n'y a pas d'écart et donc tout le
monde est découragée celui qui travaille
et celui qui ne travaille pas il faut un
électrochoc par une baisse des charges
drastique qui pèsent sur les entreprises
qu'on augmente les salaires de nos
compatriotes pour recréer un écart et
valoriser cette valeur centrale du
travail qui est une valeur
d'émancipation et pardon il nous
interrompt mais vous avez fait un livre
qui avait été remarqué parce que il
était assez iconoclaste dans ses
propositions voulait augmenter le smic
ça s'appelait milieu de cordée on est en
pleine crise sanitaire
ça coûterait extrêmement cher aux
entreprises vous souhaitez toujours avec
le précise augmenter tous les salaires
par une baisse drastique des charges qui
passe ou les gens trouvaient ça coûtera
pas un centime aux entreprises il est
hors de question on s'est dit il faut
mieux récompensés on ne vit pas bien
avec 1200 1300 ou 1400 euros nette
baisse de charge
on continue des baisses de charges
ensuite le deuxième sujet dont on parle
quotidiennement on va l'évoqué un peu
tout à l'heure par un prisme secondaire
mais important c'est la question de
l'islam politique
nos modes de vie notre identité deux
mille ans d'histoire des conquêtes comme
l'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
qui semblent aujourd'hui remise en cause
ça il faut qu'on incarne l'autorité de
l'état
le patriotisme pierre est universelle et
qu'on soit intraitable
le troisième enjeu pour les nouvelles
générations mais pas que
tout fout l'camp sur notre planète il ya
un dérèglement terrible qu'est ce qu'on
propose comme écologie certainement pas
l'écologie des verts d'extrême gauche
certainement pas je voulais lui dire
tout à l'heure l'écologie de madame
chorale et dubost qui propose un
amendement cet après midi qui vise à
créer des gibiers robots pour tourner le
dos aux pratiques traditionnelles de la
chasse on marche sur la tête
il faut une écologie populaire et ses
centrales les hauts fonctionnaires ça
suffit tout doit repartir du terrain
d'une révolution du bon sens d'efforts
intermédiaire des présidents de
département des prix dans deux régions
des élus locaux et des élus tu
ressembles à vous c'est exclu pour ce
sera j'espère les orientations les
inspirations de notre monument
d'ambition les collective de notre futur
candidat régional cerveau ça vous
intéresse centre val de loire
oui à beaucoup d'élus qui me le prendrai
ma décision dans quelques semaines et
beaucoup d'élus qui me qui me
sollicitent on verra allez c'est l'heure
d'accueillir thomas des prêts pour sa
chronique que s'est il passé ces
dernières 24 heures au palais bourbon
c'est ma journée a semblé tout de suite
[Musique]
mon sommeil à mon cerveau a dominé
l'actualité parlementaire mais au nid
cottineau id on veut exactement vous
savez ces insecticides tueur d'abeilles
que le gouvernement veut autoriser
jusqu'en 2023 dans la culture de
betteraves et bien le vote a eu lieu il
y à quelques minutes dans l'hémicycle
c'était juste après les questions au
gouvernement les députés étaient réunis
pour un vote solennel pour 313 contre
l'assemblée nationale a adopté alors ça
c'était tout à l'heure mais en fait les
débats ont commencé depuis hier ils ont
duré une bonne partie de la nuit huit
heures des changes souvent musclé sur
cette question faut-il autoriser les
néonicotinoïdes dans la culture de
betteraves sucrières votre collègue
madame compilées en 2016 avait dit les
études s'empilent aujourd'hui on peut
raconter ce qu'on veut les
néonicotinoïdes sont extrêmement
dangereux une fois de plus il s'agit de
faire payer nos déboires économiques à
l'environnement personne n'est pour la
disparition de la filière betteravière
et personne mais pour la substitution du
sud français par du sucre produit à
l'étranger dans des conditions moins
disantes alors il y avait clairement
deux camps les contres avec les
socialistes les communistes libéré
les territoires écologie démocratie et
solidarité qui portait un petit masque
abeilles et puis les autres les
républicains et la majorité qui ont
soutenu le projet de loi mais nous le
clash qu'on retiendra c'est celui entre
l'ancien ministre de l'ecologie delphine
batho et le ministre de l'agriculture
julien de normandie
alou nous oui ou non autorisée
l'empoisonnement intentionnelle des
terres de france
vous dites l'empoisonnement des terres
de france mais l'empoisonnement des
terres de pologne alors ça rien à faire
et donc demain on va continuer à
apporter un empoisonnement de terre
européenne
mais chacun pour soi une écologie du
chacun pour soi c'est pas le sens de
l'écologie que moi j'ai enracinée en
moins bon alors vous avez vu le ministre
a été applaudi mais en fait le sujet il
divise énormément jusque dans la
majorité tout à l'heure 175 députés en
marchant voté pour 32 députés ont voté
contre ont voté contre 30 6 se sont
abstenus
jamais autant de députés la république
en marche n'avait fait défaut au
gouvernement pour un texte
c'est un record alors avec émile yenni
on a cherché à interroger un de ses 32
députés qui ont voté contre parce que je
pense qu'il faut aider les agriculteurs
de la filière betterave de la filière
sucrière mais sans pour autant revenir
sur la loi de 2016 qui interdisait ces
néonicotinoïdes ce sont des pesticides
extrêmement puissant qui restent dans
les sols qui reste dans l'eau qui
s'attaque aux insectes pollinisateurs et
c'est un symbole majeur qu'il ne faut
pas toucher
on a le temps de faire une réaction
voilà mesdames prochaines étapes avec le
sénat dans les prochaines semaines vous
avez voté pour la raison dire qui
expliquait très bien monsieur de
normandie c'est que arrêtons de prendre
les français pour des imbéciles
interdire un produit en france qu'on
continuera à importer du monde entier
c'est vraiment prendre les gens pour des
imbéciles
oui elle est relative mais temps qui a
passé des alternatives soutenons la
filière betterave en france deuxième
grand thème de cette émission vous
restez avec nous guillaume pelletier la
langue arabe
laon quasiment tabou en tous les cas peu
enseignée on va le voir tout de suite le
gouvernement veut renforcer son
apprentissage à l'école pour lutter
contre le séparatisme religieux qui et
pour qui et contre celle face à face au
but
[Musique]
face à face qui oppose qui vous oppose
guillaume pelletier ce soir à yale brune
tibet bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous vous présidez la commission des
lois à l'assemblée nationale député la
république en marche des yvelines et où
et nabil wakim bonsoir soit vous êtes là
non pas pour le face à face mais bon
votre éclairage parce que journaliste au
monde que vous êtes vous signez un livre
absolument passionnant qui s'appelle la
rade pour tous pourquoi ma langue est
tabou en france est aux éditions du
seuil c'est un récit qu'est la fois
intimes mais qu'elle s'y très politique
parce que vous êtes allé voir plein de
personnalité on va y revenir c'est la
langue arabe qui est votre langue
maternelle mais que vous avez perdu
on va y revenir dans un instant mais
d'abord les clés pour comprendre ce
dossier au fond pourquoi seul un élève
sur deux mille en france apprend l'arabe
à l'école on voit cela avec nathalie
gloire
combien d'élèves à prend-il l'arabe au
collège et ici ils étaient quatorze
mille neuf cents à la rentrée 2010 9
selon l'éducation nationale soit deux
élèves environ sur 1000 ont fait le
choix de prendre arabe en seconde ou
troisième langue
les professeurs sont majoritairement des
agrégés désigné par le ministère en
primaire les chiffres sont encore plus
faibles
ils étaient 5 167 enfants à apprendre
l'arabe contre 1483 pour le chinois en
que vont devenir les locaux des locaux
ce sont les enseignements de langue et
de culture d'origine prodigués en dehors
du temps scolaire dès le ce1 par des
maîtres issus de 9 pays différents comme
l'algérie la turquie le maroc mais aussi
l'italie l'espagne et la serbie
ce n'est donc pas l'éducation nationale
qui les rémunèrent mais ces pays
partenaires des enseignements parfois
pointés du doigt pour leur caractère
communautariste
voilà pourquoi emmanuel macron annoncé
leur suppression dès la rentrée 2020
notre école ensuite ne peut en aucun cas
faire l'objet d' ingérence étrangère
nous mettons donc bien fin aux locaux ça
n'est pas simplement un projet qui
avaient parfois pu être par le passé
jt discuter
c'est une réalité que propose la future
loi sur la laïcité
l'objectif du gouvernement est de mieux
encadrer l'enseignement de l'arabe en
france afin d'éviter que les parents se
tournent vers les mosquées les
associations religieuses et les écoles
privées mais pour l'instant le ministère
de l'éducation n'a donné aucune
précision sur la manière dont
l'enseignement de l'arabe sera renforcée
à l'école et elle brawn peavey deux
élèves sur mille seulement étudier
l'arabe au collège ou au lycée il ya 4 à
dreger seulement en 2020 dans notre pays
pourquoi ça bloque ce cas un blocage
dans l'éducation nationale à enseigner
l'arabe
je ne sais pas si on peut parler de
blocage moi je crois qu'effectivement ça
il faut faire le constat et une fois
qu'on a fait le constat y apporter des
solutions
peut-être qu'effectivement dans le passé
il ya eu une réticence à prendre cette
langue à l'école
maintenant je crois qu'il ya un réel
besoin il ya un réel besoin des enfants
il ya un réel besoin des familles
on a un réel besoin aussi de nos
entreprises on a un réel besoin de nos
services moi qui m'occupe par exemple de
renseignements on voit qu'on manque de
linguistes on manque d' analyse
d'analystes qui sont capables de
travailler en langue arabe
c'est une langue de notre monde c'est
une langue de notre pays et donc je
pense qu' évidemment il faut renforcer
son apprentissage former des professeurs
parce qu'on manque également de
professeurs pour pouvoir former nos
élèves je vous donne ma parole gameplay
mais un mot quand même sur le diagnostic
parce que peut-être qui nous manque de
grands experts pour sauver le pays en
plein chaos évident qui part arabe ou
d'autres langues rares mais n'empêche
que vous expliquez bien nabil wakim dans
votre livre que c'est une langue qui est
devenu tabou c'est une langue qui est
synonyme de régression sociale
vous arrivez en france donner quatre ans
vous êtes né au liban
votre langue maternelle celle que vous
avez entendu en premier dans votre
oreille jeunes enfants c'est l'arabe et
puis plus rien vos parents ne vous parle
pas en arabe
enfin en tout cas une volonté n y pas et
vous ne la prenez jamais comment vous
expliquez ça personnellement et de façon
plus globale à l'échelle l échelle du
pays
c'est effectivement une question qui
mêle l'intimé et le politique qui a à la
fois bien sûr ce dont parlait madame
brand pbs à savoir les blocages existent
dans l'éducation nationale qui sont
certains qui sont assez lointain la
mauvaise image
qui est accolée à l'arabe les confusions
qui sont entretenues par certains
politiques y compris ici à l'assemblée
cette confusion ces stéréotypes sur
l'arabe l'islamisme le terrorisme etc
mais il ya aussi et c'est une partie que
j'explore dans mon livre cette prudence
qu'ont les femmes immigrées elle-même à
transmettre l'art avant se disant bon
comme l'arabe a mauvaise réputation je
vais peut-être pas miser là dessus et
d'ailleurs on sociologue qui dit dans
votre livre
lang perçus comme des boutons t il
estime qu'il faut rouler alors on voit
bien il ya deux exemples dans le livre
c'est les anciennes ministres myriam el
khomri ou najat vallaud belkacem elles
ont fait allemand première langue
anglais deuxième langue et latin alors
c'est très bien pour elle et c'est tant
mieux mais on voit bien que dans
l'imaginaire des parents issus de
l'immigration et ben il ya cette idée
que la ram n'est pas forcément une
langue sur laquelle il faut miser le
paradoxe et c'est ce dont vous parliez
secal inverse pour un certain nombre de
gens qui ne sont pas des arabophones ou
qui ne sont pas issus de familles
arabophone l'arabe c'est une chance
formidable d'ouverture sur le monde une
opportunité économique bien sûr de
devenir diplomate journalistes de
travailler dans leur enseignement etc
donc on a en france une très grande
tradition d'apprentissage de l'arabe une
école dite arabisante qui existe depuis
françois 1er et à côté de ça on a des
millions d'arabophones qu'ils
n'apprennent pas l'arabe dans le cadre
de l'éducation nationale c'est un
paradoxe est une bizarrerie française
gameplay est ce qu'il est urgent au fond
de rétablir une certaine égalité d'accès
à l'enseignement de l'arabe au collège
et au lycée
moi je pense deux choses là-dessus
d'abord sous sa très dangereux de la
part du président de la république
d'avoir dans une loi annoncée sur le
séparatisme la laïcité ou la lutte
contre l'islam politique parler de
l'enseignement la langue arabe pour moi
ça n'a rien à voir c'est totalement hors
sujet et ont parlé deuxièmement moyen
d'une famille modeste
je dois énormément à l'école de la
république à mes instituteurs et mes
professeurs remarquable et je crois que
fondamentalement l'urgence absolue dans
notre pays c'est que tous les français
de france parle bien le français
est-ce qu'on avait c'est incompatible
fortin des libyens je pose pas on a 21 %
des enfants en cette rentrée 21 % des
enfants de france qui ne savent pas ou
peu lire écrire compter
en quittant le cm2 l'urgence absolue
elle la chiffre officiel de l'éducation
nationale
annales pour autant que l'on développe
en seconde langue vivante première
langue vivante au lycée comme l'anglais
comme l'allemand l'arabe ne me gêne
alors vraiment pas bien au contraire
vous sur le site on a dit il ya deux
arguments d'abord c'est pas d'urgence et
deuxièmement c'est inefficace parce
qu'il faut quand même rappeler pourquoi
on parle de l'enseignement de l'arabe
aujourd'hui c'est dans la lutte contre
l'islamisme radical
plusieurs et josé très rapidement un sur
l'apprentissage des savoirs fondamentaux
on met le paquet depuis trois ans nous
on a dédoublé les classes de cp et de
ce1 et dans les zones les plus
défavorisées
donc les enfants aujourd'hui justement
nous en met l'accent sur les savoirs
fondamentaux et sur leurs apprentis ça
c'est pour le phrasé oppose pas non mais
ce que je veux dire c'est que ça ne
s'oppose pas après toutes les personnes
qui parlent deux langues étrangères vous
disent que plus on va apprendre les
langues étrangères à quelqu'un plus il
va être en capacité de travailler tous
ces apprentissages donc une langue c'est
un plus
c'est pas un moins c'est pas parce qu'on
va travailler langue étrangère on
retranche la capacité à travailler
d'autres matières voilà un hâle à
l'école est-ce que ça permet à de jeunes
élèves dont les parents seraient
d'origine immigrée ou du maghreb
de ne pas aller la prendre à la mosquée
c'est ça la question
c'est une des questions il ya deux
questions à mon sens d'une part
effectivement il faut que les
apprentissages puisse s'effectuer dans
un cadre républicain
et moi je préfère que les enfants
apprennent l'arabe avec tout ce que cela
comporte comme apprentissage de la
culture du monde du rayonnement haram à
l'école républicaine par un enseignant
qui est formé pour cela et qui est laïc
plutôt que d'avoir des enfants qui
apprennent l'arabe uniquement à travers
le coran dans un système religieux
ça c'est la première chose deuxièmement
moi je crois qu'il ne faut pas nier les
origines des gens moi par exemple j'ai
appris l'allemand en première langue
ma grand mère était d'origine munich
oise et pour qu'on a choisi l'allemand
en première langue à l'été immigrés
milieu modeste également et le choix
c'était dire mais comme ça tu vas
pouvoir aussi comprendre ce que dit ta
grand-mère qui parlait très mal le
français
tu vas pouvoir avoir ce lien avec tes
origines l'inscription dans une
transmission c'est extrêmement important
il ne faut pas nier les origines des
gens c'est encore une fois un
enrichissement là ok pour l'origine ok
pour le lien et l'enrichissement mais il
ya un débat d'actualité j'aimerais vous
ce que vous en pensez nabil wakim je
crois qu'il ya deux choses différentes
il ya une première chose qui est
effectivement de ne pas créer de
confusion un peu idiotes entre l'arabe
la langue arabe et l'islamisme la
majorité des musulmans dans le monde ne
parle pas l'arabe des millions d'arabes
ne sont pas musulmans ton profil il faut
arrêter de tout mélanger c'est pas parce
que des petits français vont apprendre
l'arabe à la mosquée qu'ils vont devenir
des fondamentalistes ou des terroristes
ça aussi c'est une confusion très grave
qu'il faut sortir de nos cerveaux par
contre ce que j'ai constaté en écrivant
ce livre c'est que l'arabe qui a pris à
la mosquée c'est surtout un mauvais
arabe qui a renseigné par des gens qui
sont pas prof qui donne un enseignement
de mauvaise qualité dans des salles qui
sont pas équipés sans manuels donc en
fait la vraie question c'est de dire si
on veut que les gens apprennent l'arabe
il faut qu'il le fasse dans un cadre pas
simplement républicain mais dans un
cadre pédagogique de qualité
c'est ça l'apprentissage des langues
vivantes et cette richesse de
l'environnent elle ne peut exister dans
un cadre on apprend une langue qui est
vivante par une langue qui est celle
d'un texte religieux qui ne permet pas
d'acheter le pain mais il a acheté le
vin ou de trouver du boulot
peut-être mais il ya aussi une deuxième
chose qui est plus profonde c'est aussi
que l'arabe c'est une langue de france
parmi les langues parlées en france
parmi toutes les langues de france que
sont le breton l'occitan l'alsacien le
créole des antilles et de la réunion et
les langues d'immigration bien sûr bien
l'arabe à sa place là dedans et je crois
qu'au fond c'est pas un débat pour dire
apprendre l'arabe
ça permet de combattre le séparatisme
islamistes ou je ne sais quoi apprendre
l'arabe c'est permettre à des français
de devenir pleinement français en
reconnaissant leurs différentes
identités leurs différentes cultures
c'est un débat au fond sur ce que c'est
l'identité française et quand guillaume
pelletier dit c'est le français d'abord
et uniquement le français moi je ne suis
pas d'accord parce que je pense que
cette priorité là elle est fausse
l'apprentissage et la reconnaissance de
nos cultures de nos langues de france
c'est ça qui fait notre force c'est ce
qui a toujours enrichi la république et
qu'il a rendus plus forts fait faire
nation et faire république passerait pas
bon j'ai pas dû la main mais je suis pas
du tout d'accord parce qu'il ya deux
visions philosophique
il faut respecter culturelle et la
vision anglo-saxonne du monde où on
pense que une communauté nationale c'est
une addition de communautés juxtaposés
moi je crois que le multiculturalisme
sont pas membres des communautés ici on
parle deux langues il n'y a pas de
communautés arabe et en france monsieur
pelletier est ce qu'une communauté arabe
en france
eh bien je crois pas une communauté
nationale ça c'est l'idéal qui parle
plusieurs langues vous savez bien sûr
langue c'est tout simple et enoh bien
dans nos quartiers populaires de plus en
plus il y à pas par rapport à la langue
par rapport aux pratiques au mode de vie
des tentations séparatistes très grave
et très lourd trop compris en fait
georges hage d'oublier l'arabe vers le
français
jusqu'au jour où les hussards noirs de
la république c'est à dire je considère
que quand un pays est fragmenté divisée
comme le il est chez nous l'urgence
absolue
c'est ce qui nous fédère et nous
rassemble la langue française depuis des
siècles est aujourd'hui mal enseignée
est en tout cas mal portée malgré vos
efforts par 20% de nos enfants
deuxièmement l'histoire de france
l'amour de notre histoire de 2000 ans
d'histoire
c'est très bien de vouloir fermer la
culture des autres très bien
c'est la culture des taux mais moi je la
mets d'abord des généraux dans sa pièce
monsieur pelletier
ce n'est pas la culture des autres c'est
la culture de la france l'histoire de la
france c'est l'histoire des migrations
c'est l'histoire de ces richesses qui
nous enrichit et bien sûr pas que mais
c'est aussi ça très bien disons c'est
c'est uniquement cette histoire la cvo
qui oublié ce qu'est l'histoire de la
république se creusent et que dont nous
sommes tous et toutes issues ici en
disant moi j'aime la france parce
qu'elle est comme ça vous aimez une
france qui ne france factice et une
france conservée dans du formol
j'ai eu la chance d'être professeur
d'histoire en collèges et lycées publics
l'histoire de france c'est pas
simplement l'histoire des rois
l'histoire de france aux gens bien
changé parce que comme bien des
statistiques lire là mais c'est
l'enseignement de l'arabe y être très
sympa ce sujet est loin du compte j'ai
déjà qui ne va pas je dis que ceux liés
nous gouvernent pour moi mais là je
respecte votre position respecter la
mienne absolument n'ont rien compris
c'est à dire qu'ils veulent ajouter des
choses différentes à l'éducation
nationale dans l'enseignement moi je
plaide pour un panier commun la
célébration de nos parts de lumière et
de nos parts d'ombré de 2000 ans
d'histoire française s'est donné le mot
de la présidente de la commission des
droits qui risque de porter ces mesures
vous avez le mot de la fin car non mais
en fait moi je vois pas le rapport ces
sujets là n'ont pas été abordés de cette
façon là lorsque l'on a introduit le
russe le chinois le japonais dans nos
écoles pourquoi tout d'un coup
l'introduction de l'arabe dans nos
écoles alors que l'arabe existe depuis
plus de 500 ans dans nos écoles
remettrait en cause notre république nos
valeurs nos histoires
vous êtes complètement à côté de la
plaque ex mari on va pas vous
réconcilier sur ce sujet là merci
beaucoup c'était passionnant s'était
passionné un peu trop court quelque
chose me dit qu'on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler je rappelle le titre de votre
livre
nabil wakim l'arabe pour tous pourquoi
ma langue est tabou en france est au
seuil et ça vient de sortir
je le recommande très belle soirée à
tous et à demain
[Musique]